الجميع يجعل هذا الأمر
مهمًا مثل دخول CrossFit ،
أعني أن كل قصة CrossFit ليست
التمرين الأكثر خطورة في العالم ، وليس من خلال إحصائيات
تسديدة طويلة
تثبت أن العدائين يعانون من
إصابات أكثر من
CrossFit التي يشعر بها العدائون بنفس الدرجة من الرعب  كما
أشعر الآن ،
ربما ليس اليوم مثل
يوم الراحة في برنامجنا ، لذا سيكون الأمر مختلفًا بعض الشيء
- مثير للاهتمام ،
حسنًا ، ما أريدكم يا رفاق أن
تبدأوا إما بصف 500 متر أو 400
متر كنت عداءًا في وقت واحد  لذلك ،
فإن العدائين الحقيقيين يتأذون كثيرًا من
إصابة لاعبي كرة القدم كثيرًا ، لذا أرسلت
عضلات ذراعي في قضيب
منهار نوعًا ما وسقطت على الكرة ،
حسنًا ، ما الذي قمت بكسره في غرفتي ،
حسنًا ، بوسطن مثبتة على خوذة ، لماذا
هل تفعل ذلك
لا شيء يعجبني حقًا أن أعيش
كثيرًا في 3 2 1 اذهب
جيدًا ابق طويلًا هنا ذراعك لفترة طويلة لا يوجد
برنامج تمرين يستحق الملح يكون
آمنًا تمامًا ،
كما أن برنامج التمرين الآمن تمامًا سيكون أيضًا
غير فعال تمامًا لبعض الأشخاص  إنها
رياضة معظم الناس هي ممارسة
الرياضة ولكنها تحتوي على عناصر من الرياضة كما رأيتم
لأنه كانت هناك منافسة أريد أن
أتغلب على الفريق الآخر
حتى يدفع الناس قشرًا ويضربوا الوركين
قريبًا ، فأنت لا تفعل ذلك.  توتر
كثيرًا في هذا الموقف السفلي ،
والنقد الآخر هو أن هذا
المتحمس في النادي يتصرف كما لو كان أعضاء
في عبادة تعرفها مثل جيم
جونز ورجل جونز مرة أخرى.
يبدو أن الأشخاص الذين
يتحمسون لـ CrossFit لديهم
بعض الحماس لمشاركتها مع الجميع إذا
أراد الناس أن يعرفوا أننا سنتحدث
عنها ولكني أحاول الاحتفاظ بها وأحاول
احتوائها على أصدقائي لأن
الجميع أفهمك حقًا
تعرف على جميع اللاعبين المناسبين ، فلنقم
بتنظيفها جيدًا ، يجب أن أقول إن هذا كان
أصعب تمرين قمت به على الإطلاق بدون
أسئلة ، أعود غدًا ونحصل
على أسئلة أقوى تفكر في
العودة إليها غدًا ، أنت مجنون